so two of our first hundred users were
LeBron James and Michael Phelps
[Music]
Nike and apple and a dozen other
companies were entering the space but
when it comes to health monitoring we're
the best game in town that really came
from an insane level of focus in the
beginning on what we were trying to
solve one of the reasons whoop has been
successful is there were a lot of
counter-intuitive decisions along that
Journey one obvious one is that would be
interesting
steal that it's worth emphasizing for
your audience why that matters so
there was a phase in building Loop where
it was so much about the next Milestone
that I was running almost exclusively on
like a dopamine engine if the company
has a great day you're feeling like a
rocket ship and if whoop was failing I
was failing what's the personal toll on
you in those moments that people don't
see I was super stressed out I was
drinking too much and I remember I was
driving my car
and I'm on the highway and all of a
sudden it's like your peripheral vision
like starts narrowing on you and you
feel your fingers and they're like numb
I actually drove myself to the hospital
and they do
um you know all these analysis on me and
like it turns out I had a
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
this show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
well
as you look back on your your life and
you connect the dots that led you to to
do what you've done now with whoop and
your professional life
um
what are those dots
well I I grew up on uh the North Shore
of Long Island
um I was always into
Sports and exercise I was super active
kid
uh my parents are
very different my dad's an Egyptian
immigrant a very
Street Smart charismatic came to this
country with very little Rose the ranks
and finance over time
my mom uh very analytical very
book smart and
and watching how they approached life I
think was a fascinating way to grow up
because they had very different uh tool
sets to solve problems and
uh I was always playing sports I was
always exercising and that eventually
LED my way to Harvard and uh and so I
was a college athlete I got
um recruited to play Squash at Harvard
and over the course of my time there uh
got very fascinated by how I could
better understand my body how I could
uh understand what it meant to train
optimally how I could prevent over
training which was a problem that I had
uh how I could really uh understand the
other 20 hours of the day when you
weren't exercising and so
that took me down this Rabbit Hole of
physiology research which we can get
into but I read hundreds of medical
papers while I was uh in school and then
ultimately wrote a paper myself around
how to continuously measure the human
body and then over the course of my time
at Harvard built up the confidence to to
start a company which was a fairly crazy
thing looking back on it and for the
last 10 years I've been building this
company called whoop we went through
that very quickly but a lot of those
things are very very unusual one of the
first unusual things is I mean we all
train we all a lot of people train and
work out and stuff but we don't then
fall into an obsession about how to
optimize the performance of our training
and ourselves what is it about you have
you been able to figure out in hindsight
what it is about you and your makeup
that made you so obsessed with that
particular
topic well it struck me as something
that uh
really didn't make a lot of sense like
you I was spending three or four hours a
day at Harvard exercising with no
information about what I was doing to my
body and yet that's a school also that
is totally obsessed with deeper
knowledge and so that in itself seemed
like a like a deep irony and then I also
was a pretty competitive person and I
was someone who was over training right
where you see you get fitter and fitter
and fair you sort of fall off a cliff
and you don't know why and that bothered
me like that bothered me that I didn't I
didn't fully understand what I was doing
to my body what was what was the missing
ingredient so to speak and I just sort
of started pulling at that thread and it
really took me down a rabbit hole over
training I've heard this time never been
sure if I've believed it because I don't
really know what it is but for someone
that doesn't know what that is what what
is over training the technical
definition is it's a continued state of
overreaching that then leads to a period
where your body is essentially in a
depressed state and what that will look
like physiologically is essentially you
your body's run down you know activities
that would normally feel somewhat easy
uh are quite difficult
um psychologically it makes you feel
kind of lousy run down symptoms similar
to being sick and depending on how over
trained you are can last you know a week
or could last month in my case that
Norma didn't last longer than a couple
weeks but it it's kind of this ultimate
betrayal right because you're pushing
yourself so hard
to get stronger and fitter
that you actually get to a place where
you're completely
broken down
had I asked you at 14 years old say 14
16 years old what you were going to be
when you grew up what would you have
responded I don't know that I would have
known but if you looked at the things I
was interested in so I was always
playing with technology which in
hindsight uh was quite predictive like I
had the first I had the first iPod in my
sixth grade class I remember so we're
about the same age so you probably
remember when the iPod came out and like
how cool that thing was thick but yeah
it was really thick and it had that like
Wild Wheel a little before that I had a
Palm Pilot like a pom pilot seven it was
like the original uh Palm Pilot that
could get internet access when I was
around 12 or 13 I had one of the first
uh voice recorders that you could speak
into and it would type for you oh wow so
it was like you know Siri but 20 years
ago uh and it didn't quite work
unfortunately but I I had this real itch
towards technology and then I think
somewhere between the ages of like 18
and 20 I I also saw this huge
convergence happening with with
smartphones with the way that computers
to me seemed like they were sort of
seamlessly moving from being on your
desk to on your lap to in your pocket to
what I perceived to be eventually on
your body or even in your body I thought
that was a Natural Evolution so I
definitely had this pull towards
technology but I think throughout uh you
know I was overcoming this feeling of
whether I should go into Finance because
I grew up my dad was in you know in
finance in fact after my freshman year
at Harvard to most undergrads do you
know different internships and whatnot
after my freshman year I did an
internship at a hedge fund my sophomore
year I did an internship at an
investment bank and my junior year I did
an internship at a private Equity Firm
so so like I did I was really flirting
with going into Finance but I think I
think this is what I was supposed to do
from everything I've read it's quite
clear to me that you're a very curious
person and my brother is very
interesting my oldest brother whenever
we when we were younger he always wanted
to understand everything and when he
became interested in something he became
obsessed in it and he went like right
down into the rabbit hole as I read
through your story on multiple occasions
whether it's meditation or others or how
the business came to be or you know your
journey to trying to figure out how to
optimize the body all of these struck me
as a person that once they get
interested in something they go all the
way down into the rabbit hole to find
out the solutions is that accurate I
think it's fair I think
it also stems from this uh
ability to throw myself out there
um
you know back to how your childhood
influences your your future uh there's
there's a story
I don't know if I ever talked about this
but uh fascinating story where I was in
fifth or sixth grade middle school
and we're doing what's called uh blue
and gold day so I went to a school
called Greenvale the colors are blue and
gold and you have this like Fair
essentially which is all sorts of
different competitions races that sort
of thing and uh there's a captain's race
at the end of the day with like the the
four people representing their their
class so to so to speak to run the fast
race and I was a I was a captain so I
was very anxious about this final race
and right before the final race was one
of the longer races like uh I think it
was three or four laps and so
uh you know if you were to run that
you'd be quite tired and I that wasn't a
race I ever ran but uh Timmy all of a
sudden was sick and so he didn't show up
for for this race and I remember uh
Peter zaloum who's our science teacher
he's walking around and he's yelling hey
blue we need someone to run this race we
need someone to run this race and I'm
kind of like avoiding even making eye
contact with this teacher because I
really don't want to run this race
and it was like he zeroed in on me out
of a distance and just marched over and
he said well you should run this right
and I said no no I've got the captain's
race I got to do that and he's like well
90 of life is showing up
the other 10 is what happens when you
get there
and like in that moment I was like okay
yeah I'm gonna go around this and I
don't even remember what happened in
that race I don't even remember the
captain's race uh which in some ways
emphasizes his point but that whole
thread of just showing up is something I
think about all the time
why why do and this is I guess a lesson
for entrepreneurship because you saw
some
I was going to say and this is links to
Something in Your Story I was going to
say you saw an opportunity but you
didn't see an opportunity did you you
were dragged by your obsession well
interest
in building whoop yeah
I definitely saw an opportunity to
continuously measure the human body and
I also saw an opportunity that uh
Computing was getting to a size and and
sort of sophistication where it could be
smaller and smaller
uh
but the poll that got me to building
this company and I think persevering
over years was that it also was a
personal Obsession to really understand
my own body yeah
because when people typically recite
their stories of how they became an
entrepreneur you get this kind of like
they put I don't know a white piece of
paper there and they're like what is the
opportunity in the market and and when I
read the quote from you that said you're
an entrepreneur before you realized you
were yeah that's true that books that
narrative a little bit which I think
entrepreneurs sometimes try and sell
because it makes them seem more
intentional
I can't replicate your curiosity and
interest that made you go off in that
journey of optimizing the human body so
I just think in society and culture
generally entrepreneurs sometimes look
back and try and make their story sound
like really really intentional when a
lot of it in your case as is the case in
mine was like I was interested in this
thing and I just kept on going because I
loved it I think that's right I also
spent a lot of time like building the
confidence to start the company like I
really didn't know what it meant to
start a company and
I mean I spent two years doing
physiology research I then took another
class that was around if you have an
idea how do you write a business plan
for it and I remember like my senior
year I was doing like the third or
fourth iteration of this business plan
and I was meeting with the MIT Professor
a guy named Howard Anderson who taught
the class and was like a venture
capitalist and at that point I wasn't
even enrolled in the class I was just
working on this business plan and he's
like he just sort of stopped he said
well at some point you have to ask
yourself is this a paper or are you
starting a company right it sort of puts
you on the spot like why are you doing
all this work and I think I
I think I did a ton of work to feel as
prepared as possible to like have the
confidence to take the leap
and I'm so glad I did but you know when
I meet young people I try to encourage
them to do as much work as they can to
build up that confidence and also to
understand that
there's a lot of things you aren't going
to know in the process of building a
company but once you make that
commitment the learnings come in fast
right and I'm sure you've experienced
that yeah yeah yeah and I see it all the
time especially in young people who um
they're using perfectionism as a way to
procrastinate
because they're they don't feel
competent already yet to so you'll have
people that you know come come up to you
and say I've been working on this idea
for two years three years and they're
making all these assumptions which they
could quite probably figure out in a
week if they just went to Market to but
it's a guys for fear I think sometimes
to guys have like I actually don't feel
ready or I don't know I don't have the
answers so I'm just preparing more I'm
waiting for that perfect moment yeah I
think overcoming a fear of failure
is a really critical step in life and
there's a lot of methods to think about
for that
I think for me it was doing a lot of
work I think it was following
my passion in some ways the reason I
feel like I became an entrepreneur
before I knew what an entrepreneur was
it was that it almost became an
inevitability that I was starting the
company unless so a choice because it
was like all I was thinking about in my
free time you know the things you do the
things you think about before bed or in
a shower you know the Quiet Moments
throughout life I think those are pretty
telling
and what role has that played that
obsession with that with solving the
problem and solving that challenge and
your general interest in it what role
has that played in your hardest times
as in when things get really [ __ ]
difficult and it's easy to quit
if you're someone that's authentically
driven and authentically curious about
that thing
must make it somewhat easier
to carry on I think for sure
it pulls you through like the the
obsession of solving a problem pulls you
through
I mean I struggled though for years uh
with building whoop it was it was really
really painful and I think an important
thing for any entrepreneur but
especially was for me was to
disassociate my own identity from that
of the companies
if you're and you you've been a young
entrepreneur so you know this
like as a young entrepreneur
I think a lot of your identity all of a
sudden gets tied up in that thing you're
creating and for me that meant
if woop was having a good day I was
having a good day if whoop was having a
bad day I was having a bad day
um and if whoop was failing I was
failing
and that's a very unhealthy Association
but it's also not true like literally
you can be taking great steps to improve
as a leader or as a manager or even as a
recruiter and certain things will happen
that may put your business sideways
and conversely I'm sure you and I have
both met Founders entrepreneurs who have
watched their company go like this but
meanwhile they're spinning out of
control right and I think the faster
that I could separate those two
identities my own and whoop the easier
it actually became to build a successful
company
is part of the reason you also our
identity becomes attached to the company
because I was thinking about why that
was that was definitely the case for me
and the answer was because my entire net
worth was was this thing as well so
coming from a background where I didn't
have money my family didn't have money
my entire net worth was this thing that
was going well so you can see how if the
company starts to struggle it's like
Steve's actually broken well I had that
too for auditory then some in some
respects I still have it today just like
given the nature of the yeah of the
value of the business the key uh the key
at least for me in building the business
was Finding ways for myself
to manage stress to manage uh the
difficulties that come with building a
company without finding myself on that
yoyo of the company's performance right
it can't be that uh if the company has a
great day you're feeling like a rocket
ship and if the company's having a bad
day you're feeling down and so a lot of
my
I think growth as an entrepreneur has
been figuring out how to have a steady
hand and how to you know sort of stay
calm through the chaos chaos yeah how
have you done that a few different
things
um
I think the first uh and probably the
most profound for me in general has been
learning how to meditate
so in 2014 so I was about 24 years old
the company was maybe I don't know 30 or
40 people
um I think I'd raised maybe 20 million
dollars something like that which
certainly felt like a lot of money and
uh
and I felt like I was really failing
like as a leader I was super stressed
out I was drinking too much and uh and I
remember having what I would later learn
was a panic attack
um you know and I was driving my car
and I'm on the highway and all of a
sudden it's like your peripheral vision
like starts narrowing on you and you
feel your fingers and they like are a
little bit numb you have this taste in
your mouth I actually thought I'd been
food poisoned because of the feeling was
so
unusual outrageous and uh and so I drove
I actually drove myself to the hospital
and I checked into the hospital and they
do
um you know all these analysis on me and
like it turns out I just had a panic
attack
but the fact that I end up in the
hospital from panic attack I was like
all right wait a sec like I gotta really
reset how I'm building this company and
growing and uh two days later I signed
up for this meditation course
Transit on meditation and uh I've been
doing it like every single day since
then about
yeah about eight and a half years later
when I sit here with CEOs who many of
which have had panic attacks yeah funny
funny enough um and they'd talk to me
about meditation I always seem to get a
similar response which I can't meditate
my head's too busy for that
well I think the busier your mind is the
more you need to meditate
I
so I learned how to meditate in 2014 and
I think there's different stages of the
way you understand meditation as well
um there's sort of a four-week check
mark
I think there's like a four month or
maybe a one-year check mark and then
there's four years plus which is
fortunately where I am today
and the fascinating thing is
what you first observe in meditating
um and I should just sort of clarify
what kind of meditation I'm doing so I
spend about 22 minutes every morning
doing this and you literally are
um you're breathing but then you start
repeating a mantra
and the idea of the Mantra is to start
clearing your mind out and you're just
focusing on the Mantra but what
inevitably happens is thoughts start to
drift in as you're saying the mantra and
you get to have this moment where you
get to decide
do I want to think about the thought or
do I want to pass it along by going back
to the mantra
so just right there in that moment you
start to realize that you can filter
your thoughts
you also get to choose to sit with
certain thoughts right think how often
in your life you might have thoughts
coming in you feel like you can't really
control what you're thinking about right
you almost like don't have that Focus
so that's the immediate benefit that you
get that you feel while you're
meditating
the more powerful benefit and this is
what I meant about feeling certain
stages of having done it is at least for
me it started to feel like I had a third
person
you know sort of watching me and I would
hear this voice in my head suddenly like
when I was about to get angry or when I
was about to be upset or and it was sort
of uh all of a sudden you're able to
sense what you're about to do or say
before you do it so the immature version
of me as an entrepreneur might find
himself saying things and being angry
and reacting
um and then sort of almost catching up
to the emotional state that I was in and
trying to reel it back whereas the the
more meditated version of me
I think has has been able to recognize
what I'm about to say something before I
say it or feel something before I feel
it and and that
it feels like a superpower
did not grow over time that third person
ability with your Transcendental
Meditation practice
I think so I mean it's I imagine that
learning how to breathe and meditate is
like any other skill and if you refine
it for weeks versus months versus years
it it gets better and it's it's
basically becoming conscious isn't it of
what's going on in your mind you're
becoming more conscious of your thoughts
and that their choices and you're not
them yeah exactly I think it it's at
least helped me stay more in control of
of my actions my feelings decisions I'm
making
and and I really recommend it to anyone
like I think it's I think it's a game
changer
2014 you cite um in a few things you've
you've spoken on um as being a very
difficult year that's when you had as
you said 20 to 30 employees you'd raise
20 million things were pretty crazy in
those early years
um did you have doubt because when I
think about the whoop story
it's competitor set are all massive
[ __ ] Juggernauts and I've I've like
from afar obviously when I got I got my
week two months ago I remember thinking
how the [ __ ] have they done that
in an environment where you've got these
big you know Steve Jobs founded
companies and this company and they've
all got billions and 200 billion in the
kitty yeah I'm like how did they get on
my wrist how did they pierce and get
you went into an incredibly competitive
market
when you did that when you raised that
20 million did you have doubts about
yourself
I think I developed doubts
um in managing the company like I always
believed in the vision uh of what we set
out to build I mean dating to 2011 or
2012 when I was doing all the research
like it was almost a straight shot from
2011 or 12 to today the paper I wrote In
2011 was titled the feedback tool
measuring intensity recovery and sleep
and like literally today our three main
metrics are strain recovery and sleep so
in terms of having a strong perspective
on what the world should look like when
the technology is built and actually
measuring all the things it needs to
Super accurately
I think building whoop was was more of a
straight line than than the average
company
where it was all kinds of zigs and zags
and chaos is uh learning one how to be a
CEO and run the company to your point
learning how to navigate competition and
we can talk more about that we've had
some interesting experiences in that
category a big theme was actually being
able to raise capital
in part because of the competition right
like it was hard
first of all for a number of years we
were building the technology before we
ever were really generating Revenue
and that's that's just a hard business
to build and it also took us a lot
longer to get the product to Market than
we thought it would right and so
you're in the scenario where
you know you're you're saying to
investors well we're getting there we're
getting there we're getting there and so
the you know the first seven years of
the company I would say or enormously
hard from just a technology development
standpoint from a capital raising
standpoint in from a business generation
standpoint because we you know we were
seven years in and then completely
changed our business model on its head
which was a bet the company moment you
know and uh and so there were just a lot
it was a lot yeah and I told you at 22
the next was 22 when you founded the
company yeah if I told you at 22 the
next seven years would look like that
do you think you would have done it
I think I would have done it yeah I mean
it was painful but I knew I was doing
the right thing like I knew I was I knew
I was in the right storm you know what I
mean like
um there were a lot of feelings of being
like my back against the wall
um there were a lot of feelings of
uh doubt
what were those feelings of doubt
you know are we going to get this thing
to Market soon enough do are we going to
figure out what the right way is to sell
it are we maturing as a as a team are we
going to be able to attract more capital
I mean again back to raising capital
we've raised about 400 million
dollars in capital day but that's still
sense when you look at the companies
we've been competing against to get to
this stage and so I was I was nervous
about that piece of it and especially
again as a young entrepreneur who's who
is Raising capital for the first time
you said team and we there co-founders
yeah
how important is that in hindsight
because I feel like you don't find out
the answer to how well you've chosen
your co-founders until a couple of years
in
yeah look I I had a great
um CTO I had a great lead mechanical
engineer we've we've built the business
together for 10 years or my CTO just
just uh transitioned to new projects
but it's been an amazing ride and I
think the
the fact that we've been able to build
this technology that has you know
through a variety of different uh third
parties been credited as being the most
accurate wearable in the market speaks
to the the technical chops of of the
founding team and I I don't take credit
for that uh so I think it's uh it's a
remarkable accomplishment and I think
it's also important when you're building
a founding team to have a a fairly clear
set of responsibilities I get a little
nervous when I hear of a founding team
and they're both like the business guy
or they're both like the technical guy
and kind of the same thing you know the
the advantage that we had in starting
the company was each category of thing
that we were trying to do was so hard
like inventing a wearable that could
measure uh hurry variability as
accurately as an electrocardiogram or
raise Capital at a time that you know
Nike e and apple and you know a dozen
other companies were entering the space
like
if I struggled with raising Capital like
I wasn't gonna have a partner giving me
a hard time if he struggled with
building the technology I wasn't going
to give him a hard time like we just
knew it was hard uh and we also knew
that the other wasn't going to be better
at it so I think that there was an
element of complementary uh skill sets
that's helpful
if you were giving someone advice on how
to pick a co-founder in terms of the
character traits that you look for in
that person what would you suggest that
they look for because it's a question I
get asked all the time our co-founders
it's probably some combination of
commitment intensity and humility
um
the commitment piece is really important
because
you're going to have a lot of very
difficult things happen in the first
six months let alone the first six years
and so you want to know that this
person's committed to doing this and
it's going to be hardcore and no matter
what happens we're going to get through
it you know I I think startups really
only fail if the founders quit or you
run out of money so like if you can
overcome those two things
you've got a pretty good shot
and and so commitment's critical and
then intensity and humility that's what
I just generally look for in anyone that
that I work for or work with you want
hard driving people you want people who
recognize that it's going to take an
enormous amount of work and discipline
to develop whatever product or service
it is that you're creating for the first
time
but you also want along the way
um to have people who recognize that
with that intensity and with that
intelligence with that depth
they have the humility to recognize that
they may not have all the answers
and in particular when you're building a
company and a small company at that that
has a lot of different departments that
intersect and then in the case of whoop
I mean Hardware software analytics data
regulatory design marketing whatever you
could have a meeting with four different
departments and it's really just four
people and all of a sudden there's this
massive Collision around how we're going
to send data from a whoop strap to an
iPhone
and like the product person has their
own perspective the iOS engineer has his
own perspective you know the the
Bluetooth expert has their perspective
the engineer has the mechanical
engineer's own perspective and so
there's this natural Collision of how
should we solve this problem and I think
when you build teams with high humility
they tend to come out with the answer
that's best for the company not like I
came up with it
so that would I think that's a pretty
good starting point commitment intensity
humility
when you think about the the most
difficult times so I know that you would
have been through many many difficult
times but when you when when I say that
when I say the most difficult time
maybe a day maybe a piece of news you
got
an email
is there something that comes to mind as
the most difficult day time moment well
there is a period of time of about 18
months where whoop never had more than
three months of Runway
of cash in the bank yeah wow so picture
that right because
um you know so much of building a
business is having the runway to
strategize and grow and recruit and and
I had the company had gotten into a
weird moment where
we were still doing Innovative things
but we hadn't found the next investor to
sort of carry the company through to the
to the Future uh to a future round or
you know give us two years of Runway
which is sort of what you'd want for any
Capital injection and
we were making some deals happen there
were there were compelling things
happening in the business and so we were
able to stitch along a number of uh
Investments but never enough capital and
so I just felt this enormous weight on
my shoulders man like it was it was so
intense and uh and it also was it was a
company size that you know it's one
thing to say okay 18 months and you
never have more than three months of
Runway something you said when you're
like a 10 person team like we were like
a 50 70 person team something like that
so you know that you feel a lot of
responsibility as well when you're
operating through a period and
essentially it got to the point where
um if we didn't get uh essentially a
term sheet signed uh on a Wednesday
uh we were gonna go bankrupt on that
Friday or file for bankruptcy on that
Friday so imagine like two days from
from it all going away and I remember
writing uh like even writing a note to
all of our investors about what a
journey it had been and thank you like I
felt all the feelings of the company had
failed without the company having failed
and fortunately was able to get the deal
done on that day and uh
yeah I'm so glad I did I've been there
I've been there for multiple payrolls I
told this funny story about it being
Payday on that day in the bank not our
bank at the time not releasing the funds
we have 200 people
um and them saying they'll only release
the funds on that Friday when everyone's
expecting payment if I get a contract
signed by one of our clients
so I'm in London having drinks with this
client and we get to like you know a
certain point at lunch but I'm like you
wouldn't mind signing this contract send
it off but multiple times especially
running a B2B agency business that was
growing cash is always 60 days away
you've got to pay your bills today but
what's the personal toll on you in those
moments
that people don't see
well I look back on that whole period
with like immense gratitude because it
being able to overcome that and being
able to
essentially pull through in a
circumstance where I think almost uh any
other business would have failed
it just it reframed for me going
forwards what it means to be facing a
challenge
like that was a real existential
challenge like this whole thing's going
away we're all going home the technology
is worth nothing right that's a that's
like poof
and so now it's like
okay the sales were lower this month in
the last month or this great person on
our team got poached by that company or
this epic competitor came out with this
product like
there's there's some level of
perspective that comes with all of those
you know big challenges because I just
remember
being able to work through the what I
deemed to be one of the biggest
challenges did you get anxiety through
that period
totally but I I also like I was able to
build a whole lifestyle and process to
approach
um stress and I do think that success
may come for people when they overcome a
level of stress that would break most
people
and so
I'm a little critical of how
um pop culture likes to talk about
stress which is if you're stressed you
know take on way less of it right and
that that may be true in small doses but
what we really want to learn is how to
cope with stress and how to manage
through it and how to overcome it and I
think also if you're stressed about
something it's also a signal that it
matters to you and it's important right
so
uh look it was that period of time was
uh
enormously stressful painful
um I felt like I had to keep some of it
to myself versus burden like a larger
team with it you know so that there's
certain burdens I do think that
um CEOs or leaders or entrepreneurs
carry or you're almost
compartmentalizing something and you
know you're gonna have to
to feel it
I'm sure you know what that feels like
yeah of course I think you know I did
that for my entire career and then I
think the shift I've seen in in culture
with leaders was covid when a lot of
companies the facts were clear like we
have to close down if you're a High
Street brand for example we have to
close the doors so that's when I think a
lot of CEOs started being more honest
with the state of play with their team
members and would say things like listen
we're gonna have to let half the team go
and this is how much money we have in
the bank if we don't get here then we're
gonna have to close down I I saw a big
shift then and it inspired me a lot
about
being transparent with my teams but I
mean for the whole of my professional
career yeah I just come I just Brave
face it was like you would have no idea
if it was the best day or the worst day
because my face was the same so you got
good at holding it in 100 but my
business partner didn't and he became an
alcoholic so he as he's talked about
many times he turned to alcohol us we
lived in the same house together sure
and he would I there were times when I
went downstairs at 3am and went into the
laundry room and he was there drinking
yeah and you know so we were we were
both coping in different ways I was kind
of compartmentalizing and kind of just
I called it a video game mindset where
it's what you've talked about I was I
was holding the controller I think my
business partner was inside the game
yeah you know what I mean as in like
there was a a chord between me and what
was going on did you develop any like
lifestyle hacks
um
I've got to be honest no not at the time
and now I think I have more
but at the time no I was just
trying to get to the next day and I
think I have a natural sort of
predisposition to in the worst moments
ever just purely focusing on what I can
control
part of me which bother is a big deal
yeah yeah I I only know this in
hindsight because I wonder why in honor
if I told you about the worst day we
ever had in the business
years later my business partner says why
were you so calm on that day well well I
had very few choices
so not the worst day we ever had in the
company my choices were so small
and they were so obvious as they often
are it's like if the room's on fire like
the doors over there and the buttons
there I think about that all the time as
like are you controlling all the
controllables and
often if you are or even just you know
setting sitting down in your mind or
even putting on paper hey what are all
the things I control about the situation
what are things I don't
that can be a very calming exercise it's
very focusing yeah even talk about that
day we made the cash flow problem I knew
what my objective was get this guy to
sign this piece of paper yeah what's
there to worry about I have no time to
worry so
um so yeah that was a but you developed
lifestyle hacks to help you
we talked about meditation which was a
big one
um
exercise big one uh
I got into hot cold transitions
gratitude's a big one
so take me through your day then because
I think this will reveal a lot of your
habits
sure so
let's take a a given day in Boston yeah
the day actually starts for me a little
bit the night before because I'm getting
into a a framework for you know the next
day
um
a few days a week I work out with a
trainer early in the morning so I'll
actually pack everything up for that
well I've got my my workout clothes out
I'll have the what I'm gonna wear to
work the next day
um I'll I'll probably have written down
like two or three things that I'm gonna
focus on the next day
and
and then like sleep because you know
building whoop you think a lot about
sleep
I uh you know I sleep in a really cold
bedroom uh really dark bedroom why cold
and dark
it's just shown to give you higher
quality sleep
yeah and I try to go to bed at a
somewhat consistent time this is a
little trickier because my wife's kind
of a night owl and I like to go to bed a
little earlier but uh so I'll probably
go to bed between I don't know 11 30 and
midnight and then I'll wake up at around
6 30 and controversial question about
your wife then does your sleep
deteriorate with your wife in the bed it
doesn't because we have uh we've got
good intimacy like we've got good bad
cuddle habits you know it's like a
cuddling ton yeah yeah we we
we've done a good job co-existing in a
bedroom environment although that's an
interesting thing you can track on whoop
so if people really want to know whether
or not they sleep better or worse with a
partner you can literally record that in
the whoop journal in the app uh so in a
second I want to hear what's in your
movement
well you probably check while you're
chagging against uh so
cold room a consistent bedtime
um
yeah and then I wake up and I'm like out
the door really quick shower workout
clothes got my stuff I always give my
wife kisses before I leave that's like a
nice relationship hack uh while she's
while she's sleeping and then uh I work
out for an hour with my trainer I'll do
uh steam room after that freezing cold
shower I do a breakfast that's mostly
like egg whites it's mostly proteins
like egg whites like avocado bacon that
kind of stuff two points there so the
first was working out in the morning
yeah is there any like dates where
science around that being advantageous
so back to being able to control the
controllables I like to work out in the
morning in large part because it means I
can then stay at work later if I need to
okay what I hate is when I go to work
without having worked out in the morning
and I'm supposed to pill I like squash
that evening and then a couple things
come up around 6 p.m and all of a sudden
I realize I'm not gonna get out the door
and so then you know you know you don't
exercise so the nice thing about working
out first is like okay I've checked that
box and then the other thing was this
the cold water
cold water yeah talk to me about why you
do that and how that helps
so
there's something I think to be said for
doing things that naturally make you
happy
even if in the moment they're a little
painful and uh for me being in the cold
is one of those things like I feel a
huge jolt of adrenaline from it uh it
also forces me to breathe properly and I
think anything you can do that helps you
breathe properly or forces You to
Breathe properly is good for you uh and
then I feel kind of happy after doing it
like like this little injection of
happiness and so I end a hundred percent
of showers that I take cold and as cold
as possible the colder the better
and then the the steam room aspect or
the sauna aspect depending on where I am
is uh
I mean there's a fair amount of research
that shows if you do a steam room or a
sauna a few days a week it is likely to
increase longevity
I would say I like the cold more than
the hot but anyway
all right Sam the opposite
my my girlfriend is a breath
practitioner oh okay Coach so obviously
you understand what comes with that and
cold water is a big part of what she um
encourages on me so she jumps in these
ice baths and I'm like I'm trying not to
feel amazing I might put my toe in and
I'm like coming up with reasons but now
she's got me into it so so what kind of
breath work do you do
um I didn't even know the name of it
she's got her own method she teaches
classes she's doing classes in London at
the moment big groups one-on-one
sessions she's doing
um she does sessions with lots of people
that come on this podcast in fact oh
cool because they end up getting getting
to know her so but
yeah I don't know what type of breath
work it is but it's an hour in a room
like the
yeah the double inhale yeah Game Changer
just yeah I think they're cool I think
it's amazing yeah that's a huge industry
that's that's feels like a wave coming
into Shore because this word breath work
showed up like 18 24 months ago over
here and now it's everywhere with like
Wim Hof that's a good point I mean Wim
Hof yeah I think Wim Hoff pushed a lot
of it especially around the cold and
I look I think it's taking off for a
good reason in part because again back
to controlling things you can control
you can literally control your breath in
a second
and there's an interesting whoop hook to
all this because one of the core things
that
led me to starting the company was
discovering this statistic called heart
rate variability and heart rate
variability is essentially this lens
into your autonomic nervous system it's
the amount of time between successive
beats of the heart so it's a little
confusing but if your heart beats at 60
beats per minute it's not beating every
second like it might be 0.7 seconds and
then 1.3 seconds and then 0.6 seconds
and 1.4 seconds and it turns out that
variability of time between successive
beats is actually a good thing
because it's a sign that your body is
able to regulate in its environment
and your autonomic nervous system
literally consists of sympathetic and
parasympathetic activity now sympathetic
is activation
so that's heart rate up blood pressure
up respiration up
um often it's what's happening when
you're feeling a little bit of stress or
you're exercising right now parasympic
is all the opposite hurry down blood
pressure down respiration down
it's what helps you fall asleep
but where this all comes back to breath
work
is literally inhaling
that's sympathetic
that's parasympathetic
so just by controlling your breathing
you can decide whether you want to be
sympathetic dominant parasympic dominant
you can increase your heart rate
variability you can decrease it and
that's something that's in your control
and heart rate variability is one of the
core statistics that we look at as a
lens into how restored your body is
I noticed that because my friend Logan
said he went up for a night out he got
drunk it was a yeah yeah and then he
screenshotted his his whoop dashboard
the next day and was and put it into our
chat and went [ __ ] because everything
was red and and he was trying to explain
to me heart rate variability and why it
was important but I couldn't quite
understand
um and I remember trying to trying to
read about why it was important but I
knew you were coming here so I thought
I'd ask you myself because you I've
heard you talk about the importance of
heart rate variability I understand now
what it is but why is it such an
important indicator and what are the
things that we do that make it plummet
so the fascinating thing about hard
variability is it's been measured since
like roughly the the 80s and
the physiology research that I was
reading in college was showing that uh
Olympic power lifters were using heart
rate variability to determine how much
they should lift So based on whether
they had a low or high heart rate
variability in the morning and they'd
get hooked up to an electrocardiogram
like this is an intense thing and then
they would go decide how much they were
going to lift based on what their
reading was I think that's kind of
interesting turned out cyclists were
doing it in the 80s the CIA was using
heart rate variability for lie detection
tests
doctors cardiologists were using heart
rate variability to predict whether
former heart failure patients were going
to have a heart attack again
so I'm thinking about myself this is a
pretty powerful statistic that I've
never heard of that feels like everyone
should be measuring and uh and so that's
really
that was one of the core insights in
building whoop was that you need to be
able to measure heart rate variability
continuously and in particular it's
going to play a huge role in helping us
understand the status of your body's
Readiness and uh how well you're
sleeping so those are two ways that
whoop is primarily using heart rate
variability
uh you know things that decrease heart
rate variability uh dehydration bad diet
we just talked about alcohol
um heavy exercise uh you know heavy uh
psychological stress
often people are surprised how just
The Wrong conversation with their
partner the night before bed
can totally throw their sleep out of
whack or their heart rate variability
out of whack
so it's a very powerful statistic it's a
fascinating statistic and I'm mostly got
like a lot more people are measuring it
it seems to know us before we know
ourselves to know how to describe it one
of the things I would say in building
whoop is
uh
feelings are overrated there are things
happening in your body that you can't
feel and I think heart rate variability
is one of those one of those key
indicators where for most people it'd be
very hard to know what their heart rate
variability was saying in any given
moment
but uh it has turned out to be a good
embodiment of what whoop does which is
that feelings are overrated I say that
because I remember looking at my heart
rate variability and seeing it was
orange or red I can't remember and then
asking myself why and I go oh yeah I
know why because I was really I think I
was really stressed that day I hadn't
slept and then I hadn't slept because we
had a back to back to back schedule so I
was going to sleep at 4am and waking up
at 8am for like three days in a row and
my heart rate variability just seemed to
plummet and that was when I speak to my
sister and I go listen we need to no
meetings before 11 because I need to
sleep
um and it knew me before I and it's
funny because it yeah it it changed my
life by telling me something that maybe
I wasn't listening to
it changed my routine by telling me
something that was clear maybe from a
subjective objective standpoint but I
clearly was ignoring thinking that I was
invincible I think covid-19 was a big
wake-up call for people in that category
right of
um of feelings are overrated because
here you have a virus that you can get
that you don't feel
you're not even sick and yet you give it
to someone else and they get deathly ill
we had a fascinating relationship with
covid-19 in being able to measure it
because we detected a statistic called
respiratory rate being super elevated
but I can't tell you how many
screenshots and messages I've gotten
over the last two years if people seeing
this huge spike in their respiratory
rate you know two three days before
ultimately testing positive for covid
and
it reaffirmed in a lot of ways the
founding story of the company although
in a different direction it wasn't about
not knowing that you should train today
or rest today it was about not knowing
that you were sick it speaks to the
potential of Health monitoring and why
it's so exciting
another conversation I've been having
recently with a friend is about
blocking out certain types of light I
heard you do that yeah so uh blue light
essentially what emits from a cell phone
a television set an iPad I mean blue
lights frankly all around us and blue
light essentially tells your brain to
stay awake
and so
one way to offset that is to not be on
devices into the evening but you know
I'm still I think largely optimizing my
life around being a great entrepreneur
or or uh CEO so for me that doesn't
quite feel like an option yet or I
haven't quite built that level of
maturity
but what I do do is I I wear these blue
light blocking glasses which have a red
tint to them and uh it's like a get out
of jail free card for using devices into
the evening and uh and then they start
to make you sleepy
it's probably the single biggest thing
that's boosted my REM and slow wave
sleep on woop is is wearing blue light
blocking glasses
it's worth emphasizing for a second like
for your audience why that matters so if
you spend
like seven hours in bed
you're not actually getting seven hours
of sleep right and if you think about
the seven hours you spent in bed it's
divided up of time in which you're awake
you're in light sleep you're in slow
wave sleep or you're in REM sleep
and awake and light sleep as stages go
really are kind of irrelevant like they
don't do much for your body
physiologically they're not restorative
but REM and slow wave sleep that's like
where all the magic happens so REM sleep
is when your mind is repairing
cognitively it's when you'll have uh
deep dreams so people who say they don't
remember their dreams or they don't
dream they probably aren't getting
enough REM sleep so for human beings REM
sleep is like critical right because
that's cognitive repair slow wave sleep
that's when your body produces about
like 95 of its human growth hormone is
that deep sleep on woop yeah yeah and so
you know people think they're getting
stronger going to the gym right really
you're just breaking down your muscles
when you go to the gym you actually get
stronger when you go to bed during slow
wave sleep because you're producing all
your human growth hormone
so just to zoom out if you're someone
who's spending seven hours in bed
it might be that you get a total of 30
minutes of REM and slow wave sleep of
those seven hours
it could also be that you get like five
and a half hours
out of those seven hours and often when
you talk to people about sleep they're
like I just don't have time blah blah
blah we're not even talking about more
time we're just saying how do you take
the seven hours that you're in bed and
make them way better
and uh and so for me blue light blocking
classes was one of those things there's
a couple others but yeah this was the
thing that made me fall in love with my
whoop I remember getting eight hours
sleep waking up and feeling great
looking at my whoop and it said you'd
had three hours REM sleep and be going
yeah smashed it that's nice yeah and
then a couple of days later or the next
day getting eight hours sleep waking up
and feeling like [ __ ] looking at my
whooping it said oh you've got 30
minutes or something and me going ah
there is it because you think oh I spent
eight hours in bed so I must have had
yeah as you say like eight hours sleep
but it's j when you once you see that
you can't unsee it it's like this whole
29 years of my life I've been like I've
misunderstood something so foundational
about my entire life and the fun thing
is you can optimize it like once you
measure it you can manage it yeah I kept
my girlfriend at the bed I said goodbye
well you don't have to go yeah you don't
have to be that extreme but it's uh yeah
I do think it's empowering and like
sweeps about a third of your life
be good to take care of that third too
but just the the difference I see on a
on a day where I've just had bad REM
sleep or bad deep sleep versus the days
when I've had good like my performance
my mood everything is so different it's
a completely different human being
also there's a fascinating phenomenon
too as it relates to stress
so research shows that the more REM
sleep you get the less heightened your
amygdala response is Right amygdala is
like fight or flight right and so if you
get a ton of REM sleep it essentially
softens your amygdala um it it makes it
less active
uh funny enough I did a a podcast with
Alex Honnold do you know who that is so
Alex honnold's the famous uh rock
climber who did free solo Oh you know
that documentary yeah yeah so he scales
this crazy uh you know slab of of
mountain without a without a rope and he
also happened to wear a whoop and so I
was talking to him about
uh risk and fear and all these sort of
different concepts stress but uh it
turns out that he gets like four and a
half to five hours of REM sleep a night
on woop
and I was thinking like how perfect is
it that a guy who literally can rock
climb and risk dying every single day
has this like unbelievable uh outlier
also ability to get REM sleep of course
and could those two things be related
the other time that I wasn't familiar
with until I got away was this idea of
strain I I'm gonna be honest I we talked
a little bit before we started recording
about my little fitness group yeah the
way the fitness group is designed is
that it's but you get it's like a league
table it's rewarded on consistency we
call it the fitness blockchain so
there's 10 of us in it if you lose you
get kicked out of the group and someone
who gets put in every month
it's quite vicious you get put into
another group you have to wait for three
months before you get one chance of
getting back in if you don't you go into
what we call chump hell story it's like
a hardcore like fantasy football yeah
it's crazy um we track it we track a lot
of things you have to submit your
workouts every day as well and then
someone verifies Etc
um strain currently in that group you're
rewarded for working out every day
is that a good thing
well
the way that we think about strain is to
balance it alongside recovery
so
the average amateur
uh exerciser let's call it the weekend
warrior
uh probably has workouts that look too
consistent in terms of intensity or too
consistent in terms of strain so whoop
has a scale from 0 to 21 on whoop that
might look like a 12. or like a 13. like
so every time they work out it's a 13.
and the reality is when your body's run
down
maybe you don't want to do anything or
maybe you should go for a walk like just
let your body recover give yourself the
permission to catch a breather
but if your body's peaking
like go crush it right take on a 16 or a
17 or an 18.
and I should also say that you know
strain is essentially looking at
the amount of time that your body is in
an elevated heart rate zone
so we're talking about a primarily
cardiovascular measurement of stress
that you're putting on your body for any
period of time
but back to your question like you
probably don't want to do
a high strain every single day unless
your body's freakishly recovering and
there are people who do that but they're
mostly like professional triathletes or
whatever
and you also want to try to vary the in
the The Strain level
so if you're at a 50 recovery maybe
you're doing a 10 if you're at a 75
recovery you're doing a 16 or 17 or an
18. and a lot of this goes back to
in building the product we wanted to
make it actionable
a lot of wearables maybe V1 wearables
sort of told you what happened
we were very focused on telling you what
to do next and how you can
uh get better on that point of recovery
then how if I if I'm training a lot
um how can I improve my recovery outside
of sleep
a lot of it would be diet and hydration
uh potentially supplements if you're
taking them making sure you're taking
the right ones
um because if you're taking the wrong
supplements that's actually a lot worse
for you than taking none uh
you know
I think some type of mindfulness or
meditation or breath work speeds up
recovery that's that's my own bias uh we
certainly see uh sleep consistency so
that's less about what you're doing
during sleep but actually more just
routine so going to bed and waking up at
similar times
even exercising at a similar time may
help you recover faster because your
body's getting used to it
of all the of all the metrics that
attract on the whoop is heart rate
variability the one you love
the most well on a personal level it was
the thing that jumped off the page to me
you know
10 years before it became even
remotely mainstream so I feel some
relationship with it in the sense that
like I saw there was a lot of potential
for this thing
on a on a whoop level
the product does now measure a lot of
different things very well so I don't
want to say that any one statistic is
the Silver Bullet I think a lot of it is
collecting all of this information in a
form fact in a format by the way that
you're willing to wear 24 7 which has
its own challenges we can talk about uh
and then creating scores or creating
messaging to an end user that that gets
them to change Behavior gets them to
improve health that to me is the if you
think about the Pyramid of you know sort
of challenging things the tip of the
pyramid is a product that is changing
your behavior and improving your health
quick one some of you may know we've got
a brand new sponsor on this podcast
American Express and you've got a brand
new exclusive offer for a limited time
only which I can't wait to tell you
about from the 18th of October to the
16th of November American Express is
offering new card members a 60 000 Point
membership reward as a welcome bonus
when you join when you spend a minimum
of eight thousand pounds across the
first three months this is simply a
thank you for joining American Express
and for those that don't know you can
use your American Express business
platinum card points in exchange for
various rewards such as booking travel
holidays gift cards and so much more so
essentially you're rewarded with huge
prizes for just using their card to
spend on your usual purchases and I've
had a look through at what sixty
thousand points can get you so if you'd
like to find out how you can get your
hands on your new American Express
business card then search American
Express business platinum card to find
out more I've had so many people tag me
on Instagram even on Telegram and in my
Twitter DMs in a picture of them
starting their heal journey and it's one
of the most amazing things in my life
that I get to do a podcast which of
course needs money to to fuel and I have
a sponsor like Hill who I genuinely
believe is going to help every single
person who starts their heel Journey
change their life because this podcast
the central intention of this podcast is
to help people live better lives it
gives me my protein it gives me my
vitamins minerals it's plant-based it's
low in sugar gluten free it does all of
that in a small drink that tastes good
there are other products there's Foods
there's the hot and savory collection
many other things but for me this ready
to drink is the absolute savior of my
diet throughout the week where I'm
moving at such Pace look I don't want to
labor the point but if you haven't tried
he'll give it a try and if you do tag me
Instagram wherever you try it give me a
tag anyway back to the podcast your
company
um the business you've built
I heard that your employees that would
get a bonus if their sleep is considered
to be good on their whoop how much truth
is there to that it's a fun uh it's a
fun employee perk that we came up with
so
everyone on woop is on a team together
and you can opt into What's called the
Sleep bonus and if you get 85 percent uh
sleep performance on average throughout
the month uh you get a hundred dollar
bonus like on your pay stock and so it's
it's mostly uh it's mostly a fun thing
but it does speak to our culture which
is
using the data we have in front of us uh
promoting uh sleep and good habits
actually during covid we also came up
with the red recovery policy which was
because we had a lot of people actually
coming into the office during even
during the peaks of covid because we
built Hardware accessories supply chain
things that you kind of have to do in
person very physical things and so the
red recovery policy was that if you had
a red recovery
you actually uh needed to stay home
because either you are getting sick or
you are at risk of getting sick because
your body was run down so again fun fun
ways to use the data in an actionable
way and and you know build it into the
culture
when you talk about why your company has
done so well and it has one you talk
about there being a more Scrappy kind of
nature to the team
which sounds more like innovation
how does one go about as your company
grows keeping that Innovation that's so
Central to you winning because with
growth often cut becomes like I don't
know things move slower you know
bureaucracy before being for Jenny's
come back from annual leave
what are you doing from a culture
standpoint
I think one of the reasons whoop has
been successful is we had a pretty clear
perspective on what we were building and
why
and the consequence of that is also what
you're not building
right like whoop is graded all the
things that it does for all the things
that it doesn't do
we are
not a smart watch
we don't allow you to download a bunch
of apps we don't receive phone calls
you can't flag an Uber with your whoop
right but when it comes to health
monitoring we're the best game in town
and that
really came from an insane level of
focus in the beginning on what we were
trying to solve
and it carried us through to today
there were a lot of counter-intuitive
decisions along that like along that
Journey
um one obvious one is that whoop is not
a watch
uh and I can't tell you how many people
have asked for whoop to be a watch and
the reason it's not a watch is is
there's a few different reasons but just
by putting the time on it all of a
sudden you've created this enormous
competitive landscape
and competing with watches is hard like
there's a lot of beautiful watches
there's also a lot of watches that serve
different functions
watch also says a lot about your
identity
the other thing about a watch and you'll
notice this from every technology
company is the second there's a screen
there's this enormous scope creep that
occurs for what the product's actually
meant to do
and very quickly you're in a product
meeting where you're talking about email
notifications and different screen
colors and various ways to tell the time
and whether or not you're going to be
able to give it voice memos and and all
of a sudden you're talking nothing about
health monitoring
and so if I look back and
um you know over the last 10 years
we made these decisions so like we made
a decision to not be a watch uh and not
have a screen on it
we made a decision on the flip side
though to invent a modular charger
where you could charge your move without
ever taking it off
and that was super expensive and took
you made the product take way longer and
cost a bunch of hundred dollars but
again it was back to that identity of
Health monitoring needs to be 24 7 to be
the most effective and if you take it
off all of a sudden it's not 24 7 you
might not put it back on
so that was something we did that other
people didn't do right
um everyone was measuring steps
we didn't think steps was
physiologically relevant
so we we tried to stay true to our
identity and I think that helped us
navigate a competitive landscape where a
lot of people were copying each other or
where companies may have had even too
much resources and those resources got
them down you know into this very
expansive place without being great at
anything
focus and first principles is what I
heard throughout that that what you said
there the first principles point about
24 7 monitoring yeah that's like a
totally first principles thought because
you said well health is a 24 7 thing so
we have to create a solution we don't
take the watch off convention says no
just get charged and you take it off at
night you put it by your bed and you
signal so
that approach and that conviction
towards like thinking for yourself about
this problem
is much easier said than done for
companies like t i I feel like peop one
of the you know in all facets of our
life whether it's our relationships or
intimacy or friendships or building
companies or how we construct teams
thinking for yourself is what I heard
there
um you say it so easily but it's wise
it's impossible for people to do
especially when they're thinking about
innovation
because you know you had all those
moments where why doesn't this have a
screen on it so also why I love it it's
probably also why the battery lasts
longer it's also why I'm so committed to
it as you've identified but those are
all like
first principles that came from whoop I
think what
what's different about your product is
also what makes it special and I think
that true Innovation often comes from a
level of focus or discipline that's
really uncomfortable
like having said everything I just said
I still think about whoop as a watch on
a near daily basis because
it's it's something that pulls at me you
know because
I can see a world in which it is a watch
but it's not a watch and I'm not
building it as a watch you know what I
mean so there is this uh
you know sort of painful level of
discipline that has to occur I think to
be able to continue marching forwards
and we actually went a different
direction where
uh We've looked at invisible as a more
compelling landscape so obviously you
can wear it on your wrist but you can
actually you know take it apart and
depending on what garments you're
wearing right so you take this clasp off
you can now put this sensor into
different places on your body so really
so yeah so we've come out with shorts uh
boxers bras underwear uh uh shirts that
have it in your arm sleeve and so you
can just tuck this into a little pocket
that allows you to wear it in different
areas of the body
I didn't know that so I could put up my
boxer shorts lining yeah oh nice dope
yeah now also kind of crazy to start a
wearables company and realize you're
designing boxers but that goes back to
your first principal's point I suppose
right yeah exactly why would you design
boxers well because you need to create a
way for them to wear it 24 7.
something else you said which I've never
had anybody say before but it's so
unbelievably true is when people have
bigger budgets when six like with
success comes greater temptation to be
and do everything and become everyone
and that's often when companies lose
their way
is because of their success everyone
goes well why don't we do we've got
these customers now so why don't we do
this and that and this and why don't we
do it five of them
have you felt that temptation
yeah absolutely I mean uh I think it's
that's probably the biggest way that
success
uh is a bad teacher is the degree to
which it makes you think you can go into
a bunch of things and abandon the level
of intensity or Focus
that you took in building the original
thing to be successful
so
but you know that doesn't stop me from
dreaming of ways that the company can go
in totally different directions
you just you have to check yourself like
you really do have to check yourself and
make sure
uh
you've got the right level of focus if
you're going to go into it that's been
one of my biggest mistakes is we become
successful I then come up without new
ideas I then think more about the reward
of the new ideas versus the actual cost
the cost of like mental time for the
whole team the cost of like everyone
waking up and being in the shine
thinking about a different problem
and then we had a recent incidents where
we spent I'm going to say nine months
planning something big big new thing in
one of my companies
offered someone a job to be the CEO of
this this new company and then I don't
know what it was something in my gut
says you're doing it again Steve you're
losing focus
cancel it all and it's funny because my
team was so excited Jack was so excited
we're all so excited about but when I
had that conversation with everybody
about why we were canceling this because
I know we should be focusing there was
this weird jack because you know what I
was so excited but I'm relieved and we
all knew we all knew we'd got carried
away with
thinking more about the reward of this
Focus than the cost of this Focus I
think this focus is a thing but has that
happened to you when you've like ran too
far down a path with a new idea
and then range yourself back in because
you realize the cost of focus
yeah I think there's there's been
certain aspects of
product development you know go to
market strategies where
you know it's the right thing even
but you you're again you're not
dedicating the right level of focus to
it or the team doesn't have the
bandwidth for it or uh the timing's not
quite right like
yeah I mean Focus I think is probably
one of the most underrated
uh skills for any leader and not and I
don't mean that just for them
it's more important that they create an
environment of focus
how does one do that if I if I join
whoop how am I going to learn
on the day before I join the day I
joined and thereafter every day why I'm
here this this Vision the focus how are
you how are you teaching me that well a
lot of it comes back to the core mission
of the company right which is to unlock
Human Performance to improve health a
lot of it comes back to being really
deliberate about the hardware that we
build and why the accessories we build
and why a lot of it comes back to
the fact that whoop is a subscription
right we haven't touched too much on
the business model but
transitioning the whole company and the
whole business model to being a
subscription versus a one-time Hardware
sale changed a lot for the company uh
but one thing that it it really changed
uh for the better is the DNA around
launching new features launching new
Analytics
you're no longer trying to get a
customer on an 18-month cycle where you
come out with the new widget or 12-month
cycle where you come out with a new
widget you're trying to keep your
customers every day right because every
day they have a choice to cancel
and
what in turn that does is it makes you
very focused on releasing new features
that are adding value now
you could have a like a conversation
that's two or three depths deeper than
this which is around well should we go
down the path of releasing these
features or those features do those
features feel less focused than these
features right but all of a sudden at
least we're two or three levels down in
terms of focus and uh and so that's
where a lot of the debates are taking
place is within the lens of our already
focused Mission and and areas of
innovation should we pursue different
categories or different features and I
do I think like to think it's it's very
customer-centric because
uh because we have this deep
relationship with our members where
they're wearing the product 24 7. and
I think rightfully so we have to earn
their their subscription every month
competition
you've got some big competitors I mean I
saw the I saw Apple's recent
announcement that sleep is now going to
be part of the Apple watch one of the
new Apple watches maybe on the Apple
watch hate or something
how do you think about competition and
what role is that that played in
motivating you terrifying you all of
these things
yeah so when whoop was starting
uh
Nike which is a company I looked up to
with great admiration I was just coming
out with the Nike fuel band
uh Adidas was coming out with the me
coach
uh
Under Armor about a year or two later
was going to spend a billion dollars
spends a billion dollars
acquiring three different companies in
the space they were coming out their own
wearable they bought a a Running Company
um
a company called Endomondo a company
called MyFitnessPal so they had a whole
strategy around Health tracking
there was a company called uh Fitbit
which was about to go public for you
know many billions of dollars a company
called Jawbone which had raised a
billion dollars
uh it was rumored Apple was entering the
space it was rumored
um Microsoft was entering the space
so
competition was always in this backdrop
but I I found I never found myself that
um swayed by what the competition was
doing
in fact if there's any company I'm most
critical of their strategy in the
wearable space it was Nike
because Nike is
I think one of the best brands in the
world and they built that brand have you
read the book Shoe dog I haven't I
haven't it's a great book anyway it's
Phil Knight's book but they built that
brand by
uh
storytelling and authenticity and the
authenticity being the people who wore
their shoes ran faster and jumped higher
and so that was the company I was the
most nervous about because I was afraid
if they could build a wearable that
their world's best athletes actually
wore
they could then tell that story to the
masses and be successful
but they took a huge shortcut
and that shortcut was they just built a
product they thought the mass Market
would like
and so it wasn't a product that LeBron
James was going to wear or Serena
Williams or Tiger Woods I mean they had
all the best athletes in the world
and so the clue to me that that product
was going to fail was that
it didn't stick to their identity they
didn't have the story at the top they
didn't have any of their top athletes
wearing it
and on the flip side the opportunity I
saw
was if we could get the world's best
athletes to wear whoop we could in turn
build our own brand around performance
and around an aspirational product
and
if you go back and like looking back on
it that was a that was a very stubborn
perspective again and
um you know even a little bit arrogant
to say uh that
now we're going to build this technology
and the world's best athletes are going
to pay us for it because it's going to
be that good
I also though think it was a fairly
rational perspective
because if you build a product that
someone needs to wear 24 7
and they don't love it there's no amount
of money you're going to be able to give
them to keep that thing on their body
let's be honest and in many ways I saw
that with the fuel band
on the flip side if
if you can really deliver value around
sleep or recovery or you know these
measurements that at the time a
professional athlete had never had
uh they're very very likely to pay for
it because that's a huge value add in
their overall performance so that was
our very early go to market strategy and
it was also part of the way that we
differentiated ourselves from other
products
the last thing I'll say about this is
and again inspired by Nike
the idea that you could build a brand or
a product that says something about your
identity like the difference between a
cotton shirt that's plain versus a
cotton shirt with a swish on it like the
person who's wearing the switch feels
something different the person who
observes the person wearing the swoosh
thinks something different that was a
phenomenon that resonated for me at a
very young age
but when I looked at the health
monitoring landscape uh
to me it felt like Health monitoring was
actually definitively not cool
and wearing a health monitor there was
almost a stigma associated with it
unfortunately
so how can you build a technology that
people wear 24 7. that has a positive
identity associated with it
and that goes again back to the
professional athlete strategy if we can
get the world's best athletes to
authentically wear it then we can tell a
story about how health monitoring is
aspirational
it's interesting because I sat here with
Scott Galloway earlier on and Scott
talked to me about how once upon a time
maybe 30 years ago
um because of the way we learned about
products and the lack of
trip advisors and review sites and
Amazon reviews
the big the big companies could could
sell a fairly mediocre product based on
just pumping advertising at like
traditional advertising like TV and
stuff so you'd go out and buy the
Procter and Gamble soap or whatever just
because you'd been overwhelmed with
advertising from it in the modern era
when we're all we have social media
accounts and we have you know ways to
broadcast from the palm of our hands and
we have WhatsApp so we can speak to our
friends about ideas and products and
stuff it's he was saying to me it's
become more about
the product and actually being great
then the advertising dollars spent so he
said it's no it's no um surprise that
the biggest companies in the world like
the Teslas
they don't they don't advertise it's
about you telling me about how much you
love your Tesla and the way that I came
to learn about my whoop was my friend
Ash a year ago raving about it like
you'd paid him I think you paid him
the way he was going on about it was
like you had paid him personally that's
great and then obviously you know and
then he eventually gets me into it and
we have a fitness group so we start
talking about it you can't pay for that
it's a better product and I think now
more than ever that's become much more
important to the consumer I think that's
right I think there's a certain
authenticity that consumers gravitate to
whether they're intentionally
recognizing it or not
and yeah for us that's been core to our
identity we've had very unusual
relationships with athletes and uh I
think in large part because we've been
able to build the technology that
they get value out of LeBron James is
one of them that's often cited as being
a whoop wearer that must have been
pretty surreal to see him wearing it so
two of our first hundred users were
LeBron James and Michael Phelps [ __ ] you
know and this was in like end of 2014
early 2015 and uh it was also a very
difficult time for the business as we
talked about earlier
but I remember I was sitting at home
with my parents uh
at this point I think the jury was out
in their mind whether me starting this
company was a good idea or not like a
couple years in like I had raised money
but you know uh was there a business
and this amazing thing happened where a
commercial came on and it was LeBron
James in a Kia commercial wearing a
whoop strap
and I thought isn't that the coolest
thing like you wouldn't even take it off
for a Kia commercial and uh and it also
made me feel good in front of my parents
did they accept that it's a real
business from that point onwards I think
it helped marginally if they accepted it
yet but interestingly it was uh
it was something that for a couple years
did buy us time for for like building a
real business was the fact that we could
get all these really
high profile athletes to wear the
product without endorsing them it
demonstrated I think to investors or
others that okay there's something real
about this technology that's different
on that point of investors
you've raised 400 million in capital
roughly yeah 100 million dollars in
capital how important is it when it
comes to picking your investors to pick
the right ones because I've seen this
kind of make and break companies
I think it's really important that
you're aligned with the investors on
what the purpose of the company is and
you know as a consequence also what the
purpose of the capital is we certainly
had investors along the way who
wanted to put money into the business
but wanted it to go in a different
direction than what I thought was the
right direction and so I'm grateful that
I never took that capital
I think
it gets more complicated when you've got
a Believer and that believer invests in
you and your business and then whatever
you're building takes longer or the
revenue hasn't quite come in yet and all
of a sudden the believer starts to
become a non-believer
that's where you start to learn
who your investors really are you know I
think that's when you start to learn how
a functional a board of directors is
like when things are when things are bad
how's everyone behaving and so
it's super important in the selection
process certainly with with investors
and I think reference checks are really
important and I think alignment on what
you're trying to do with the capital
what your identity is as a company
but I think equally important is
learning how to manage your board and
your group of investors when stuff isn't
going well we have something in common
which is you don't like networking it's
my idea how that's good research that's
how I know you're good at this I [ __ ]
hate networking and then when I read you
didn't like networking I thought ah
that makes two of us
yeah I think it's overrated it's often
advice too that's given to
young people I I think if you uh
find a particular problem industry like
fill in the blank something you want to
solve a passion of yours
it pulls you into meeting the right
people and that's where showing up is
really important that's where going to
the thing that you're half invited to
you need to go you know what I mean
versus being invited to something that
you're not sure about or whatever
pulling yourself into those environments
is critical
another piece of advice you gave to CEOs
was this which I found fascinating which
is there's a difference between hearing
and listening
what did you mean by that
so back to some of the earlier stages of
the company
um
I mentioned it was hard to raise capital
for the business and
you know I heard no a lot like I was
rejected a lot in building this company
and
the coping mechanism for that especially
when I was I would say I was a slightly
more immature leader the coping
mechanism for that was to kind of put up
a wall to negativity
to the point where
I wasn't listening to it and I wasn't
hearing it right it was like it wasn't
there
and that was an effective and highly it
was an effective coping magic mechanism
for a very short term period that would
not at all have allowed me to scale a
business
and I had a
uh an advisor and and really Mentor at
the time who said to me you know well
you don't have to listen to what people
say but you should just hear it
and that was a helpful and very simple
way for me to just reframe
the way that I thought about negative
feedback like
okay this person disagrees with me I'm
going to absorb that I'm going to sit
with it I'm gonna wrestle with it
and interestingly now over the course of
10 years you know disagreement's almost
a source of excitement for me because it
allows me to ask myself this question of
how do I
know what I know why do I feel so
strongly about something and it really
makes you again wrestle with it and
hopefully debate it with someone who's
smarter than you is going to prove you
wrong I mean that I think is what's so
exciting about building a dynamic team
and you know taking on whatever
challenge you've got that speaks to the
importance of humidity again doesn't it
and why that's such an integral thing
when you're hiring or picking
co-founders you know I've also heard you
say that um customers are really great
at telling you what's wrong but not very
good at telling you the solution to
what's wrong
I think that's important I think it's a
very helpful framework I mean
back to starting the company I went out
and met with all these coaches and
athletes and asked them okay if you
could have any technology improve your
performance what would it be and they
were all super focused on exercise type
equipment could be measuring stress
could be GPS analysis could be video
analysis form analysis it was it was
hyper focused on the thing the sport the
exercise but when I asked them what like
what are your biggest problems managing
a team or being an athlete it almost
always came back to some form of
availability so injury or over training
like not being optimal on the day you
needed to be optimal
and so I thought there was a huge
mismatch between
the solutions they were asking for and
the problems they were describing and
for me that's that's something I just
try to think about
when I'm listening to customers or when
I'm thinking about products is
am I do I clearly understand what the
problem is or am I focused too much on
what a solution could be
am I hearing too much of the solution or
am I hearing the problem and if you hear
the problem
then all of a sudden you're building
something pretty different
interesting
you hear the problem and then you can
kind of first principles up to solve the
problems accepting probably conventional
orientated solution I thought the best
way to solve problems around
Athlete Performance was measuring the
other 20 hours of the day
and at the time that was super
counter-intuitive
but that again that word
counter-intuitive seems to be come up
over and over again when I read your
story about being a contrarian and being
counter-intuitive and this goes back to
the point about Innovation and thinking
for yourself because when you don't
think for yourself you just accept
convention that seems to be a really
consistent thread throughout your whole
journey not easy to do
not easy to do especially when things
get tough and everyone goes see
convention was right will
important to develop a process for
conviction and then to to really sit
with something that you're convinced
about and pressure test it and bat it
around and even let other people
pressure test it
but if you have a track record of that
conviction
working out then it you really have to
you have to stick to it because it's
ultimately what's going to make you
successful
sometimes I worry about that
that you know you can you can be you can
win so many times in a row that you
might stop listening and you might you
know
oh it's worth noting that
the level of conviction that we've
talked about on certain things yeah
is not a level of conviction that I feel
like all the time about a lot of things
you know what I mean
and
and I think it's worth it's really worth
emphasizing that like in building this
company I've had doubts about an
enormous number of things
so
it's important not to look at any
entrepreneur and think that person has
all the answers like I haven't met that
person yet
I I just think it's
it's a really useful process to figure
out what are the things that you feel
the most strongly about
in the product or service that you're
building
because when you figure those specific
things out and then you dig your heels
in on them
a lot of magic can happen around that
what's something you think you're wrong
about with whoop
or you might be wrong about if you've
got a creeping suspicion that there
might be something fun fundamental to
whoop that you might have been wrong
about in terms of your hypothesis
well
I think a lot of the answers to that are
also things that we're actively working
on and building so it's a little bit
sort of a little bit closer to the
secret sauce if you will then then maybe
your your question intended I'm more
than happy for Secret Sauce there's a
natural tension that occurs when you
grow as fast as woop has over the last
call it
three years four years
and where your Market goes from being a
certain level of elite athletes to
Fitness enthusiasts to everyone where
you have to ask yourself how much are
you designing the product
for everyone versus one of these
segments
and so
there's there's certain aspects of the
the rate at which we would help
someone who's trying to lose weight
versus someone who's trying to improve
sleep versus someone who's trying to run
a marathon versus someone who's training
for the World Cup
like the rate at which were
curating the whole experience to that
individual experience
I think is it that's an aspect that I
asked myself a lot about how are you
thinking about that at the moment I
believe it should get much more
personalized and even the degree to
which certain statistics that you see or
don't see May evolve depending on your
core goal
um so that would be an example of
you know an area that we're working
through and
wrestling with I have no doubt that
people have approached you to buy whoop
no comment
so
I'll tell you a story
in 2000 and
we talked a lot about competition in
2000 and I want to say like 1718 it was
around that time that up had clearly
built great technology but we hadn't
quite figured out the distribution side
of the business or even the business
model
we were approached by Amazon
and
Amazon was interested in
first investing in the company but then
they also got interested in potentially
acquiring the company and we weren't
interested in selling the business at
the time but in the process of
evaluating an investment
we shared a fair amount about the
company right and certainly information
that you wouldn't want to share to
Amazon a potential competitor Amazon and
fast forward two years later they came
out with a product that was a direct
knockoff of a whoop strap that's not
like Amazon yeah well you know you feel
it differently when it happens to you
that's for sure
but
look it goes back to some of the resolve
of the of the company and the I think
that the culture at whoop where we do
feel kind of David versus Goliath
we are comfortable with people coming
after us and we're not threatened by
competition because the day they
announced that it was almost like a
running joke within the office it wasn't
okay we're screwed it was
that's gonna fail you know and we're
gonna we're gonna see to it that we
succeed so in any way it was like almost
energizing that uh that they did it and
of course it's nice now to to see that
the product I think hasn't quite been as
successful as they would have liked or
maybe um
I don't think they're releasing a future
version of it when your team said that's
going to fail what gives you that that
conviction what is it about what you see
in your walls and knowing about what's
going on in their walls that makes you
go you're not we're still going to win
I mean I don't want to be critical of
them I think Amazon
is a pretty amazing company and I'm sure
has an enormous number of amazing people
I think what
what's inspired what inspired whoop in
that moment is the same thing that
inspired us for 10 years which is that
we see things a little differently if if
someone is going to try to copy
everything that we've done before
they're still not going to have the
special sauce for what we're going to do
next
and even when we created our uh whoop4
on the circuit boards we wrote
um don't bother copying us we will win
and it was this great it was this great
like call out to the engineering team
and in fact every single engineer who
worked on who before their initials are
on the circuit board oh really so real
sense of ownership and the funny thing
of course about putting a line like that
on a circuit board is the only person
who's ever going to see that circuit
board is someone who's trying to copy
you
so you know I think there's I think
there's ways to roll with these things
and
um you know challenges ultimately are
what help you find your identity what is
the end then what is the end goal for
you
you're an entrepreneur you've done this
for more than a decade now entrepreneurs
start thinking about taking money off
the table about selling about you know
going and working on some other
challenge in the world where is your
brain I know this is a difficult
question to answer and I know what it is
for you on team members and investors
and but where are you at what can you
tell me I think one thing that's
potentially unique for whoop versus
other businesses that that I could have
started or or an entrepreneur might
start is that it's actually gotten
exponentially exciting as it's grown
like I'm as energized today running the
company as I've ever been running the
company
and and I've met Founders who for you
know no fault of their own are actually
just in a different place with that like
they're 10 years in or even six years in
and they kind of feel like they've hit
their peak of the mountain and it's time
to bring someone else in and
they'll stay involved as a chairman or
maybe it's the right time to sell it for
me it's uh
it's it's really as energizing a time as
I can remember building it as you have
more and more people on the product as
well it creates I think more and more
momentum for it
it's also a product that you see people
wearing all the time so
like everywhere I go I now see whoop
which is pretty like pretty amazing just
given that uh once upon a time it was an
idea on a piece of paper
and and so that you know that's still I
still find that energizing
I've got an amazing team
and the future for health monitoring I
think is really to be able to
predict something about your health that
you otherwise couldn't feel that is
either going to improve your life or
it's going to save your life like I
think Health the potential of Health
monitoring is so profound
that uh you know it determines a
full-time my full-time attention for now
we have a um tradition here where the
previous guest asks a question for the
next guest
um they don't know who they're asking
the question for
and I don't know what the question until
I open the book the question that's been
left for you is
this is kind of funny
um
they maybe didn't realize your age when
they wrote this but they said what would
you tell your 25 year old self
I'm going to change this to what would
you tell your 22 year old self
keep going you know it's going to work
out
I think
learn to separate
gratitude from complacency
I think
I think there was a phase in building
Loop where it was so much or even just
growing as an entrepreneur where it was
so much about
the next
Milestone and getting to that next
Milestone that I was running almost
exclusively on like a dopamine engine
right and you tell yourself
okay getting to this milestone's really
big deal
and you're going to be really happy when
you get to this milestone
and that has a that has a an important
physiological effect in that it
literally creates dopamine because
you're anticipating this thing
um
but then when you get to that thing
if it's not the thing that you thought
it was going to be there's this huge
letdown
and so
in the process of living on that sort of
dopamine wheel
I learned that you really need to
um introduce gratitude and be
appreciative of all the steps and people
and products that are happening along
the way
and I think there's a misperception for
entrepreneurs at least I think there was
slightly a misperception for me which is
like okay if I stop too much to
appreciate
where I am or this moment or what's
happened
I'm not gonna have the drive to get to
the next thing that's actually not true
at all like you can be very appreciative
of where you are today and still
entirely driven to get to the next
milestone in your in your mind
so as opposed to to re-answer the
question it'd be learning how to uh to
balance
gratitude with Drive
and that makes the whole journey
sustainable totally yeah
that's how you can go for like
multi-decades and still and not get
burnt out or that's how you sprint the
marathon
well thank you thank you for your time
thank you for making a product which is
just exceptional and you know it
probably sounds like I'm kissing us or
I'm like making this up because you're
here but I genuinely I mean you can
check my account
by the way we don't check accounts I
know previously is like number one for
you guys
so thank you for being on Loop and I
appreciate the way you do this you do a
nice job no I'm so unbelievably curious
and
um it was such amazing timing that we we
got to have this conversation shortly
after I became obsessed with my week
because I have so much to ask you not
just about the watch but about building
a company that is taking on these
incumbents and done such an unbelievable
job of it and I think now I know I
finished this conversation understanding
why and it's about that that focus on
the vision it's about having really
um clear principles that are driven from
a real real sense of like authentic
curiosity obviously hard work and all of
these things and great people are huge
factors resilience grit and all those
things and then it's again about the
Innovation that's behind me which comes
from those principles which has allowed
you to continually think from first
principles because the whip is very
different
and so that that for me is clear like a
like a book like Harry Potter it means
it's come from a very singular vision of
the world it couldn't have been this is
not the byproduct of
huge amounts of um
consensus
that's fair yeah see what I mean because
a group of people would not have thought
of this that's right they would have put
a screen on it with the thing and but so
it's really remarkable to meet you and I
have no doubt that you know this company
is going to continue to go from strength
to strength so thank you for being here
thank you Stephen quick one I have some
exciting news this episode is brought to
you by Mercedes-Benz who recently got in
touch to support the Diary of a CEO
thank you I've been quite the fan of
their cars for some time now so I jumped
at the chance to work with them as one
of the most well-known luxury Brands out
there and through getting to know their
brand on a much deeper level I came to
learn about our shared values on
Innovation striving to create a better
tomorrow some of you may know if you
follow me on Instagram that this year we
invested in a Mercedes-Benz of our own
and honestly it's transformed my life
but not only that we also use
Mercedes-Benz to pick up all of our
guests on this podcast this way the dire
Visio experience really starts from the
moment they're collected and we can be
in total control of how that
introduction looks and feels over the
coming weeks I want to talk to you about
Mercedes EQ which is their all-electric
car range and how they're Innovative
Next Generation technology sustainable
benefits are changing the game in terms
of their electric driving for businesses
but in the meantime if you'd like to
stay up to date with the full range and
find out more about how Mercedes-Benz
can work for you and your business
search Mercedes-Benz Fleet and let me
know how you get on quick one as you
might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when I put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]